to get people an update on the hundreds
of passengers from to Holland America
cruise ships with confirmed confirmed
coronavirus cases they are flying home
without being quarantined in the United
States now they do not have symptoms the
Rotterdam and zaandam docked at Port
Everglades Florida yesterday after weeks
at sea the van damme in particular had
been denied entry to several countries
nine people aboard tested positive for
the corona virus and four people have
died but as men while Bojorquez reports
there are worries that some people may
be going home as silent carriers it's
gonna be a very controlled exit Florida
Governor Ron de Santos applauded local
and federal officials for finalizing
what he called a thoughtful plan more
than a dozen passengers who needed
immediate medical assistance were
already transferred to nearby hospitals
passengers on board both ships received
health screenings yesterday those
cleared for travel would be taken by
private bus to charter planes over the
next few days some local officials say
this was the best possible outcome how
do you allow the ship to come in without
affecting our community I think the deal
today that we struck was a win-win
Broward County Commissioner Mark bogan
says he advocated for a 14 day
quarantine at a local air force base but
that fell through do you feel
comfortable with the way the situation
has been handled right now absolutely
not
I really have a lack of trust in what
the cruise line was telling us another
ship the Coral Princess plans to arrive
at Port Everglades on Saturday
in a statement Princess Cruises said 12
people on board tested positive for
kovat 19 commissioner bogan says they
may need to go elsewhere we just cannot
have more people with our medical system
we don't have capacity and capacity is
part of the reason some passengers will
stay on the sand and those who are sick
but not critically ill will receive
treatment there and the cruise line says
many passengers going home had been self
quarantined to in their staterooms since
March 22nd both Holland America and
Princess Cruises say they are complying
with CDC guidelines for offloading those
passengers Anthony
man well thank you